[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission pour bien démarrer la
soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'information des idées
pratiques et des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie le détail du programme
de ce 17 janvier
jeudi très compliqué en prévision les
syndicats appellent à une mobilisation
massive ce 19 janvier contre la réforme
des retraites conséquences de grosses
perturbations sont à prévoir dans le
secteur des transports de l'éducation ou
encore de la santé on fait le point dans
cette édition tout au long du mois de
janvier période traditionnelle des vœux
TV 78 reçoit les maires de 50 ans en
Yvelines pour parler des grands projets
de l'année 2023 dans leur ville ce soir
focus sur Voisins-le-Bretonneux sobriété
énergétique et qu'aux quartiers de la
remise à quoi faut-il s'attendre la mère
de la commune Alexandra Rosetti et notre
invité et puis la culture l'un de nos
invités à jouer dans plus de 90 films et
une trentaine de spectacles Bernard
Pinet signe apocalypse républicaine dans
ce seul en scène le comédien de
Noisy-le-Roi dresse un état des lieux
critiques de la société avec tout de
même des rires inattendues
et on en parlera tout à l'heure avec lui
dans notre partie culture on fera aussi
le focus sur ardèle ou la marguerite
c'est une pièce de Jean arnouille et une
création contemporaine de la compagnie
packsart production qui viendra nous
parler de ce projet en cours dans les
Yvelines du côté de la commune de
Triel-sur-Seine sur ce plateau je vous
le disais aussi une invitée politique
Alexandra Rosetti bonsoir maire de la
commune de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
également vice-présidente de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines alors vous
avez fait le choix de ne pas présenter
de vœux à la population en tout cas de
pas les présenter lors d'une cérémonie
traditionnelle vous avez fait le choix
de le faire lors d'une vidéo pourquoi ce
choix justement pour des questions de
d'économie tout simplement parce que
quand on fait une cérémonie dans un
équipement comme un centre sportif par
exemple il y a les coûts sont importants
puisqu'il faut un injection un magellite
enfin bon voilà donc faut faire un
cocktail bon et comme les temps sont un
petit peu difficiles en ce moment avec
l'augmentation de toutes les
augmentations qu'on vit on a fait le
choix de continuer comme on avait fait
l'an dernier avec la crise covid de
faire des vœux numériques mais on
parlera notamment d'une thématique celle
de la sobriété énergétique qui est
forcément dans toutes les têtes au début
de cette année 2023 on restera avec vous
également les grands projets les grands
dossiers de la commune en 2023 ce sera
tout à l'heure dans cette édition avec
nous également les journalistes de la
rédaction de TV 78 régénéralèch Michael
elodoro bonsoir à vous deux avec vous
Régine on ne va pas faire les prévisions
météo mais plutôt les prévisions côté
grève il y a la grève jeudi contre la
réforme des retraites et ça s'annonce
très compliqué être dans plusieurs
secteurs vous allez nous en parler dans
un instant avec vous Michael ce sera les
informations du jour ce qu'il faut
savoir de l'actualité chinoise de ce
mardi 17 janvier alors comme tous les
mardis également les insolites de
Véronique Iturbide c'est une nouvelle
chronique que l'on vous propose pour
voir quels sont les actualités insolites
du département des Yvelines et puis
notre astuce du chef hommage ce soir à
la cuisine italienne en cette Journée
mondiale de la gastronomie italienne ça
vous évoque quoi la gastronomie
italienne Michael si je vous en parle je
vous avoue ça m'évoque les pizzas les
pâtes mais je sais que ce n'est pas que
ça mais moi j'adore je pense que
personne ne peut détester la gastronomie
italienne c'est une cuisine que vous
vous aimez beaucoup beaucoup et j'ai
d'ailleurs appris récemment que les
pâtes à la bolognaise je crois ou
carbonara je sais plus c'était avec un
œuf donc
fraîche beaucoup de restaurant italien
peut-être à Voisins-le-Bretonneux il y
en a quelques-uns ou qui font de la
cuisine italienne je crois que c'est
devenu incontournable un peu partout et
on donnera tout à l'heure l'astuce du
chef pour bien réussir sa pâte à pizza
maison mais avant tout cela petit coup
d'œil à la météo de demain
une journée très fraîche en prévision ce
mardi dans les Yvelines des éclaircies
le matin mais surtout des températures
négatives attendues dans la partie est
issue du département au moins 1 degré à
Versailles est Rambouillet et 0° et le
matin à Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan dans
l'après-midi ça remonte légèrement pas
de pluie au moins c'est l'essentiel côté
température il fera à 5 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 4 degrés à Versailles ou
dans et Rambouillet ce mercredi 18
janvier nous fêterons les Prisca
et on passe tout de suite aux
informations de ce mardi à 17 janvier
avec vous Michael el midoron on commence
avec le chiffre du jour 18 % des
stations-service des Yvelines sont à
court de carburant sont les sites de
l'état de Total énergie 5% des stations
seraient à sec sans gasoil ni essence
dans les autres stations il manque au
moins un carburant du côté du syndicat
professionnel qui représente 5800
stations les stations ont au moins un
mois de stock il faut éviter de faire le
plein par précaution même son de cloche
du côté du gouvernement qui ne compare
pas la situation actuelle à celle de
l'automne dernier le verdict est tombé à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'affaire du marché
du Val Fourré l'affaire avait fait à
polémique ces derniers mois les 8
prévenus de l'affaire du marché du Val
fourrés ont été condamnés ce lundi 16
janvier par le tribunal correctionnel de
Versailles ces derniers avaient été
jugés en fin d'année dans une vaste
affaire de raquette organisée sur les
marchands ambulantes total près de 2
millions d'euros ont a été détourner en
disant selon les investigations de la
police judiciaire de Versailles l'ex-mer
par intérim de Mantes-la-Jolie Sidi
elheimer a écopé d'un an de prison avec
sursis d'une peine de 5 ans à déniner
l'éligibilité vous avez réussi à le dire
à Rambouillet cet événement qui s'est
déroulé aujourd'hui c'est la finale
régionale Île-de-France de la 18e au 20e
des jeunes bergers oui à Grégory c'est
un rendez-vous à très attendu par le
monde de l'agriculture ce concours qui
s'adresse aux jeunes de 16 à 24 ans des
établissements agricoles étaient
organisés ce mardi à la Bergerie
Nationale objective devenir les
meilleurs jeunes bergers d'Île-de-France
pour cela il participe à des épreuves
théoriques et pratiques inspirées des
gestes quotidiens de l'éleveur de brebis
il devait par exemple trier à des brebis
ou encore vérifier la santé des animaux
au total ils étaient qu'un jeune
participant présent dans les Yvelines
aujourd'hui on écoute une participante
au micro de tv78 on a plein de
techniques et de manœuvres à faire qui
sont différentes de ce que moi je fais
au quotidien
et non c'est ça change du quotidien les
deux candidats arrivaient en tête du
classement de la finale territoriale
défendront leur chance au Salon
International de l'Agriculture ce sera
le 25 février prochain on a commencé
avec le chiffre du jour mais un nouveau
chiffre à présent Mickaël qui concerne
la SPA
9766 c'est le nombre d'animaux prise en
charge par les 6 refuges SPA
d'Île-de-France pendant l'année 2022 la
Société protectrice des animaux vient de
communiquer son bilan de l'année
dernière ce chiffre toujours trop élevé
est en recul de 9% par rapport à l'année
2021 une baisse également mais du côté
des adoptions il y a eu 3% d'adoption en
moi par rapport à 2021 trois refuges de
la SPA sont implantés dans les Yvelines
on retrouve le site d'Orgeval Hermeray
et de plaisir on termine Mickael par une
information sportive l'affaire fait à
grand bruit ces derniers jours le PSG
pourrait quitter le Parc des Princes en
effet un bras de fer oppose la mairie de
Paris qui ne veut pas vendre la
structure au prosters catarin qui
veulent quant à eux acheter et
moderniser des lieux il y en a un qui a
sauté sur l'occasion c'est Carl l'olive
le député de la douzième circonscription
des Yvelines a posté à montage photo
d'un stade avec le logo du Paris à
Saint-Germain avec le commentaire et
alors ce tweet montre qu'il est
disponible à disposer à accueillir le
PSG dans les Yvelines sûrement dans sa
circonscription à vers Poissy et
dirigeants parisiens pourraient investir
plus de 600 millions d'euros dans un
nouveau stade pour rappel Poissy elle va
déjà accueillir le futur centre
d'entraînement du PSG dans les prochains
mois les joueurs devraient s'y entraîner
dès la saison prochaine merci Michael
pour toutes ces informations juste vous
préciser qu'une information nous nous
est parvenue on vous en dira plus
peut-être au cours de cette édition où
on prendra le temps d'avoir un peu plus
d'informations et on vous relira cette
information demain une perquisition qui
est s'est déroulée au conseil
départemental Dans le cadre d'une
enquête ouverte en juin 2022 et conduite
par l'Office anti-corruption et la
police judiciaire de Versailles un peu
plus d'informations peut-être à vous
donner dans la suite de cette édition
merci encore Michael et propose aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'une
information d'un fait qui vous fait
réagir dans le département des Yvelines
n'hésitez pas à nous le dire sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7 8 news
[Musique]
à deux jours de la grève nationale
contre la réforme des retraites ce jeudi
à 19 janvier ça se précise des
perturbations sont prévues dans les
transports les écoles ou encore dans les
raffineries bonsoir réginera leche
rebonsoir avec vous donc on parle de ces
prévisions de ces perturbations à qui
s'annoncent à quoi doit-on s'attendre
alors vous l'avez dit plusieurs secteurs
seront touchés par le mouvant social ce
jeudi du côté des transports la
circulation pourrait être très perturbée
notamment en Île-de-France et syndicat
et de la RATP et de la SNCF ont appelé à
je cite une grève puissante dans les
Yvelines il faudra s'attendre également
à de fortes perturbations les lignes CN
et U seront fortement impactés on estime
entre 70% et 80% des conducteurs en
grève et selon Mathieu bol Réda le
secrétaire général de la CGT Chemino
Versailles moins d'un train sur 3
circule rage jeudi le plan de transport
sera disponible ce soir à 20h sur le
site du Transilien
et comme la annoncé Michael Ely Doro
sachez également que certains employés
de raffinerie se mettront en grève ce
qui a suscité la panique chez les
automobilistes dans plusieurs
départements et dont celui des Yvelines
ou 18% des stations services sont à
court de carburant en ce qui concerne
l'éducation à quoi faut-il s'attendre
que des fermetures d'écoles par exemple
sont prévues jeudi et la grève a déjà
commencé ce mardi 17 janvier pour les
écoles du 1er degré les syndicats de
l'éducation nationale se sont mobilisées
et revendique la revalorisation de leur
métier dans les Yvelines 82 écoles
primaires étaient fermées aujourd'hui et
en ce qui concerne la grève de jeudi sur
un panel de 300 écoles primaires déjà
63% d'entre elles ont déclaré leur
intention de se mettre en grève de leur
côté les professeurs des collèges et
lycées n'ont pas l'obligation de se
déclarer grévistes 48 heures avant le
jour de la grève mais la mobilisation
s'annonce aussi importante selon
Delphine Romani secrétaire
départementale du SNES FSU pour les
parents qui nous regardent c'est pas
d'ailleurs à vous rendre sur les
différents sites internet de vos
communes pour vous renseigner sur les
situations locales un petit mot aussi
sur la grève dans le secteur hospitalier
ça s'annonce dur aussi le secteur de la
Santé prévoit lui aussi de se mobiliser
la CGT santé et action sociale à déposer
un préavis de grève pour la journée du
19 janvier le mouvement pourrait
toutefois avoir moins de répercussions
que dans d'autres secteurs puisque la
fonction publique hospitalière on le
rappelle est soumise à un service
minimum voilà donc pour ces informations
c'est prévisions à deux jours de cette
grève nationale contre la réforme des
retraites merci Régine ralech sur la
commune de Voisins-le-Bretonneux est-ce
que vous avez déjà vous en savez déjà un
peu plus sur par exemple les écoles qui
font pas accueillir d'élèves ce jeudi
oui on a un gros mouvement qui est bien
suivi et la difficulté qu'on a c'est que
c'est également suivi bien sûr dans le
personnel communal c'est-à-dire que ce
soit les animateurs ou les agents de
cuisine ménage qui fait que les communes
ont une obligation théoriquement de
service minimum quand enseignants sont
en grève mais si nous n'avons pas de
personnel pour assurer ce service
minimum et bien nous sommes un petit peu
coincés donc c'est c'est ce qui va se
passer à Voisins j'ai trois écoles qui
vont être impactées nous organiser
comment du coup c'est le service minimum
mais qui peuvent pas forcément être
appliqués c'est ce que vous quand on
peut on va l'appliquer mais comme on a
aussi des agents qui font grève et bien
on ne peut pas l'appliquer
systématiquement partout et on va voilà
on est en train de communiquer auprès
des parents pour qu'ils puissent prendre
leur disposition dans l'émission PAF
Patrice Carmaux c'est c'est invités
revenaient notamment sur une autre
actualité on parlait de la réforme des
retraites et de cette grève et aussi le
départ le débat sur le port de
l'uniforme à l'école et l'intervention a
notamment un de Brigitte Macron en
faveur de cet uniforme pour le
politologue Armel Le Bras Chopard la
première dame n'a aucune légitimité pour
intervenir sur un texte sujet regardez
un extrait de l’émission paf c'est un
vieux débat alors le débat est ancien ce
qui est nouveau est complètement
surprenant c'est
attention de la femme de
d'Emmanuel Macron n'a rien à voir dans
le dans le débat actuel qui est que
autrement plus large et autrement plus
important et en plus elle n'a absolument
aucun titre à intervenir dans un débat
public que ce soit l'uniforme que ce
soit
l'orthographe l'écriture inclusive la
pédagogie
absolument c'est une citoyenne comme les
autres alors
à la suite de son intervention il y a eu
évidemment des réactions y compris un
deuxième article dans Le Parisien et
l'Élysée a répondu ah ben oui mais elle
a pas envie d'être une pétiche mais on
s'en fiche que Brigitte Macron est en
vie ou non d'être une potiche personne
vous avez pas envie d'être une petite
moi non plus
nous apporte comment une personne qui
n'a absolument quinté qui n'est pas élu
qui n'est pas nommé
intervient et court-circuite le ministre
de l'éducation nationale
il s'était déjà prononcé en disant non
il y aura pas d'obligation au niveau
national même si tel ou tel
établissement peut dans son règlement
mettre des
uniformes etc c'est absolument
incroyable et c'est un acte qui est
politique alors qu'elle n'a pas
intervenir en politique ces politiques
n'ont pas tellement sur le fond et sur
le sujet mais précisément parce qu'elle
va à l'encontre d'un ministre de la
République qui lui a une fonction
officielle et puis deuxièmement parce
que elle intervient sur une proposition
de du rassemblement national qui n'est
quand même pas n'importe quel parti
politique
est une émission à retrouver en
intégralité sur notre site Internet et
notre application mobile TV 78 alors on
reçoit ce soir donc je le disais la mère
de voisin lebretonneux sur tout le mois
de janvier on reçoit l'ensemble des
maires de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et
une thématique on le disait on
commençait en parler en début d'émission
qui est bien et réelle pour toutes les
communes aussi pour l'ensemble des
Français c'est le de l'explosion des
coups on parle depuis quelques mois
aussi de du terme de sobriété
énergétique qui est l'une des solutions
pour faire face justement à
l'augmentation de ses coûts qu'est-ce
qui est vous prévoyez de faire dans
votre commune qu'est-ce qui a déjà été
fait à Voisins-le-Bretonneux alors on a
été obligé effectivement de d'agir donc
on a en particulier réduit les activités
pendant les vacances donc dans nos
équipements sportifs et culturels on a
même fermé pendant les vacances de Noël
avec avec les associations que je
remercie parce que elles ont vraiment
fait preuve de responsabilité et en
février va fermer une semaine sur les
sur les deux parce que les associations
doivent aussi faire des stages on des
compétitions etc on a baissé bien sûr la
température partout que ce soit dans nos
équipements publics dans les écoles pas
dans les crèches par contre pour le coup
là non et puis on éteint les lumières
bon ça c'est avec l'agglomération
puisque notre éclairage est
intercommunale voilà toutes les pistes
de d'économie évidemment sont mises en
oeuvre étudiées ça aussi ça guide aussi
nos choix budgétaires à venir puisque on
voit bien que le coût des fluides je
sais pas nous on a pris depuis 2021 on
est à plus 400% pour le gaz et à plus de
100% pour l'excès l'électricité les
mesures d'urgence
en 2023 alors de grands projets on va
parler des grands dossiers de voisins
breteux vous étiez venu nous parler d'un
autre dossier qui a été lancé ses
voisins 2035 c'est bien ça c'est en soi
imaginer que les habitants
une telle qu'elle sera dans une
quinzaine d'années est-ce que ça va se
poursuivre sur l'année 2023 cette
réflexion oui alors déjà l'association
science civique qui a mené tout ce
travail doit nous rendre son récit
partagé puisque le livre able c'était un
récit partagé donc ils vont ça va être
fait en début d'année et probablement
qu'il y a des thématiques sur lesquelles
on va pouvoir rebondir et utiliser ce
que les habitants nous ont dit parce
qu'on a une ville qui est
perpétuellement en transformation et en
mouvement et donc c'est important de
voilà de s'inspirer des
idées des habitants pour avoir des
directions qui correspondent le plus
possible à leurs attentes justement il y
a la poursuite de ce chantier aussi en
2023 à Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec le
concours aussi de 50 ans en Yvelines
c'est cette ZAC de la remise cette zone
d'aménagement concerté les travaux ont
été lancés depuis l'an dernier alors
quelques chiffres un plus de 500
logements seront construits sur 10
hectares plusieurs équipements
un public et des commerces avec un
objectif qui était annoncé l'année
dernière c'est des premières livraisons
dès l'année 2023 est-ce qu'on pourra
tenir cet objectif non l'objectif c'est
2024 mais on parlait de première
livraison fin 2023
en fait on a fait le choix de de faire
le quartier d'un seul tenant pour
d'abord créer le moins de nuisances
possible pour les riverains enfin que ça
dure le moins longtemps possible et
également pour que les tous les
promoteurs mutualise et fassent des
économies qui leur réinjecte dans dans
quelques innovations donc pour l'instant
on va être première livraison fin de
premier trimestre 2024 et ça va s'étaler
sur toute l'année 2024 je précise juste
que les images que l'on vient de voir
c'était au début du chantier ça a bien
évolué depuis mais en tout cas on voit
des des vues d'artistes qui
il y a quelques griffes qui montrent ce
à quoi ressemblera cette ZAC de la
remise alors il y a une actualité aussi
qui avait fait grand bruit dans la
commune fin 2022 c'est une
officialisation de la fermeture de
l'école du bois de la Garenne et ce à la
rentrée prochaine juste rappeler
pourquoi nécessaire de fermer cette
école mais parce que nous avons une
baisse du nombre d'élèves dans d'abord
sur toute la commune depuis quelques
années on a perdu plus de 1000 élèves en
15 ans on va dire donc c'est aussi une
baisse de la population c'est tout voir
ensemble et
revoir la carte scolaire ne servait plus
à rien parce que tous les ans il y a des
classes qui ferment dans différents
groupes scolaires donc les parents s'en
inquiétaient évidemment et donc revoir
la carte scolaire ne servait plus à rien
c'était déshabiller Pierre pour habiller
Jacques etc donc on a fait des études
sur l'état de nos bâtiments sur les
perspectives pour remplir nos écoles on
va dire il se trouve que cette école là
coche plusieurs cases c'est elle est
énergivore c'est pas la seule mais elle
est ramenée au nombre d'enfants c'est
une des plus énergivores les enfants
baissent de fois tous les ans et comme
nous sommes dans un quartier uniquement
pavillonnaire et bien ou les pavillons
sont très chers il y a pas possibilité
de ramener de nouveaux enfants enfin en
tout cas de nouveaux habitants
et
puis on a une école à un kilomètre qui
peut accueillir les enfants donc très
très bonne condition donc il faut un
moment que nous qu'on rationalise nos
équipements et j'ai envie de dire que la
crise énergétique que nous vivons nous
donne raison et en 2003 vous allez
lancer une concertation pour décider
justement ce qui va devenir de ce site
tout à fait voilà c'est un engagement
que nous allons tenir nous allons
démarrer en mars une concertation avec
les habitants de la commune c'est pas un
projet de quartier c'est un projet pour
la commune c'est un terrain qui nous
appartient donc voilà on va pouvoir
discuter de nos besoins et puis
aboutir j'espère en juin au moins au
concept ou à l'idée de ce qu'on pourra y
mettre et ça mettra fin je dirais à
toutes les élucubrations qu'on peut
entendre ici et là ça s'est acté pour ce
nouvel équipement une nouvelle crèche
dans le quartier de la remise dès cette
année alors la crèche les travaux vont
commencer incessamment sous peu ce sera
une crèche une écolo crèche elle sera
labellisée
en plus sera chauffé la géothermie
c'était l'occasion avec des travaux de
cette ampleur voilà donc il y a une cuve
de récupération d'eau qui a été placée
là qui est déjà en place qui nous
permettra d'arroser l'été quand on est
en période de sécheresse de pas mettre
de faire aussi des économies de ce point
de vue alors vu qu'on est sur les
équipements sportifs il y en a un qui ne
le sera plus bientôt c'est le stade du
champ du loup qui va devenir un
cimetière oui alors c'est beaucoup moins
gai évidemment mais c'était devenu
indispensable et incontournable puisque
le cimetière notre cimetière est
quasiment plein donc là les travaux on
espère vont commencer probablement en
avril et vont durer un petit peu moins
d'un an
ce sera ça a été un long travail parce
que beaucoup d'études de sol enfin c'est
très complexe un cimetière et ça prend
beaucoup de temps une problématique
aussi à Voisins-le-Bretonneux je me
souviens on en parlait sur les débats de
des municipales de l'année 2020 celle de
la circulation
c'est un carrefour un voisin de
Bretonneux on le rappelle entre 50 ans
en Yvelines la vallée de Chevreuse donc
beaucoup de
la circulation est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à des nouveautés sur le plan
de la circulation je crois qu'il y a un
travail qui va être mené avec 50 ans en
Yvelines sur le sujet c'est mieux que ça
c'est-à-dire que là nous avons travaillé
avec 50 années-lumines et le département
puisqu'on est sur une départementale et
donc là ça y est nous avons acté donc il
y a 4 Carrefour qui vont être
retravaillés réaménagés et travaux vont
débuter dès cette année puis l'idée
c'est de faire les travaux avant les
Jeux olympiques de l'année prochaine qui
vont passer par la course cycliste va
passer par là donc là nous allons avoir
des travaux importants qui vont générer
pas mal de nuisances mais qui devraient
permettre un petit peu de à qui sont là
pour permettre d'améliorer la
circulation
tout en préservant la sécurité
évidemment des piétons donc gros travaux
à prévoir sur 2023 mais c'était attendu
depuis très longtemps et on a fait un
travail enfin mes élus en tout cas en
charge de ça on fait un travail
extraordinaire voilà vous parlez de jeux
olympiques et les étoiles dans les yeux
de notre journaliste sport Michaël Mido
j'avoue que j'en ai également avant cet
olympiques
des pyramides qui sont
international de tennis de table de
paratinis de table donc tennis de table
handisport qui a été accueilli sur place
donc ça se prépare des gens des cette
année c'était échéance ça se prépare et
d'abord on a un club de tennis de table
qui est extrêmement dynamique et qui a
aussi été skipping voilà au skipping ça
dépend
donc voilà donc on est très très content
on va accueillir des pongistes de Corée
du Sud je crois
et donc on attend c'est après c'est eux
qui décident quand est-ce qu'ils
viennent donc on est très contents
olympique avec plusieurs sites qui
seront d'ailleurs juste à côté de la
commune aux Voisins-le-Bretonneux sur le
site de Guyancourt le Golf National et
aussi ce vélo de national à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il y en a
d'autres à Élancourt notamment il y aura
aussi des temps culturels à prévoir sur
cette année 2023 je crois qu'il y aura
une exposition sur l'histoire de dans le
Bretonneux on pourra redécouvrir
l'histoire de Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec
le partenariat avec le musée de la ville
on fait une exposition sur l'histoire de
voisins et puis on va implanter ils sont
prêts il y a plus qu'à les poser des
plaques des panneaux qui vont retracer
un peu l'histoire des lieux parce que
voisin était un petit village avec 300
habitants et c'est devenu une petite
ville on va dire de maintenant on est
plus on a un petit peu moins de 11000
mais on est à monter à plus de 12000
habitants donc on veut redonner enfin
que les vicinois se rendent compte un
petit peu garde en mémoire je veux dire
ce passé rural qui fait partie de nos
racines les dernières choses dans vos
vœux vidéo j'ai noté la date du 26 mars
vous avez annoncé un événement vous
pouvez pas nous en dire plus ça va être
extraordinaire donc
comment dire
on va avoir un musicien de renommer
mondial qui va venir qui va venir à
voisin qui était le qui allait je vais
vous le dire quand même c'était le
grec slave qui est le jour d'harmonica
de Johnny
donc on va avoir tout un événement
autour de ça avec des surprises et ça va
être une journée assez inédite à un
voisin le Bretonneux et on est très
enthousiaste voilà c'est ce sera le 26
mars merci de l'avoir 70 ans pour
terminer cette entretien et l'interview
express
avec Sandra Rosetti je vais vous poser 5
questions on pose les mêmes questions à
l'ensemble des maires qui viennent sur
sur ce plateau en janvier une exigence
des réponses courtes oui un nom un pour
ou contre parfois quelques explications
je vous demandais ça n'excède pas 20 à
30 secondes pour pour ses explications
première question est-ce qu'en 2023 vous
augmenterez les impôts locaux dans votre
commune c'est en cours de simulation on
est en train de faire des calculs parce
que c'est on est dans une situation
compliquée à cause de tout ce qu'on a
dit à tout à l'heure notamment sur
l'explosion des coûts côté circulation
certaines communes ont fait le choix de
passer à une limitation de vitesse à 30
km/h dans dans leur commune est-ce que
dans le centre ville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est envisageable
mais ce que vous êtes pour ou contre une
telle mesure je suis pas spécialement
pour mais on parce que je pense qu'il
faut une hiérarchie des vitesses mais on
travaille sur des zones à 30 voilà mais
pas forcément toute la commune certaines
communes ont aussi fait le choix du bio
pour leur cantine vous êtes pour ou
contre une obligation dans les dans les
cantines en termes de bio une incitation
peut-être
donc c'est un enfant qui a de l'oxygène
qui est directement branché au niveau de
sa trachéotomie c'est plutôt du soin de
confort pour Jodel 8 ans le nettoyage de
sa trachée est quotidien cet enfant vit
au centre pédiatrique des côtes au loge
en Josas cette structure accueille 58
enfants malades dont une quinzaine sont
polyhandicapés comme je tel ses parents
viennent plusieurs fois par semaine de
Montreuil pour être auprès de lui
Joda c'est une grossesse qui a été
normal pendant les échographies tout et
tout on n'a jamais su que il avait une
malformation c'est le jour de sa
naissance je crois le lendemain le même
jour il a fait une réaction à l'homme
quand on lui donnait le lait ça passait
par
scénarine tout ça il est tout fait il
n'arrivait pas à prendre le lait les
médecins le diagnostics une laryngo
traquée aux Malachie sévère une
malformation lui empêchant une
oxygénation suffisante des poumons à
l'âge de 6 mois il arrive dans ce centre
pédiatrique pendant les premières années
de Jodel notre château était notre
maison
je vivais au château avec Jodel on avait
une on avait une chambre donc l'équipe
soignante était devenue notre famille
c'était devenu notre quotidien c'est un
autre maison le château son lourd
handicap l'empêche de pouvoir rentrer au
domicile auprès de ces trois frères les
parents ont fait une demande pour
obtenir un logement plus grand et plus
proche l'espoir de pouvoir accueillir
Joëlle prochainement
[Musique]
chaque semaine des ateliers d'éveil
musical sont organisés au centre pour
les enfants objectifs fourjaudel essayer
de stimuler ses sens autour de divers
instruments un moment d'échange et de
partage avec sa famille vu maintenant
que on sait qu'il l'entend et que il
réagit beaucoup par le son donc on
cherche tout ce qui est musical tout ce
qui fait des paroles voilà ça fait un
petit moment d'échanger avec lui parfois
il va s'ouvrir parfois il va suivre du
regard et puis parfois non même il va
même s'endormir donc bon on cherche à
faire c'est tout simplement essayer
d'éveiller un peu les enfants et puis
apporter un peu de joie si on peut si on
les stimule pas d'une quelconque façon
et qu'on n'arrive pas à échanger on peut
vite créer de la détresse chez ses
enfants le centre aimerait développer un
système de communication permettant à
Joël d'exprimer ses envies grâce à la
reconnaissance
oculaire d'une tablette le projet estimé
à 100.000 euros est à la recherche de
donateur
je serai là
toujours pour toi
un peu plus d'informations à vous donner
concernant cette actualité que nous vous
révélions en début de journal et cette
perquisition au conseil départemental
Dans le cadre et du enquête ouverte en
juin 2022 et conduite par l'Office
entier corruption et la police
judiciaire de Versailles et ce pour de
motif atteinte à la probité et aussi à
la suite de signalement de l'Agence
Française antique corruption et de
l'association de lutte contre la
corruption ça c'est donc une information
qui est révélée par nos confrères de
l'AFP une information complémentaire
également à vous donner de nos confrères
de France Télévisions à côté de cette
perquisition au conseil départemental
une perquisition également au domicile
de Pierre Bédié le président du conseil
départemental qui est soupçonné selon
France Télévisions d'avoir favorisé les
affaires de son beau-frère et d'un ami
entrepreneur dans le BTP dans un projet
immobilier nous essaierons également de
développer un peu plus cette information
dans notre journal de demain à présent
on va passer à une partie culture dans
cette édition
[Musique]
avec plusieurs invités plusieurs
personnes qui m'ont rejoint en plateau
déjà sur ma gauche il y a Mathilde
grandjus c'est bien ça oui la
prononciation est bonne et vous êtes
accompagné de Christophe Jacquier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes venus nous
parler d'une pièce ardèle où la
marguerite c'est une pièce de Jean
Arnaud mais qui est en cours de création
par votre compagnie qui s'appelle paxa
production en quelques mots par exemple
sans production c'est pas une compagnie
c'est une association de production et
de diffusion d'artistes et de projets
d'artistes de d'auteurs et donc là en ce
moment nous sommes en
préparation pour la pièce d'ardèle ou la
marguerite avec Christophe Jacquier qui
m'a contacté pour cette pièce et donc on
s'occupe d'artistes aussi bien du
théâtre que dans la musique
voilà mais bon mais en ce moment comme
on est l'association est taxée sur
hardelou la Marguer et bien on a
beaucoup de travail en fait en amont
avant de pouvoir arriver jusqu'à
jusqu'au stade de la Seine et on va
présenter tout ça dans un instant
également à Véronique Ithurbide à ma
droite qui rejoindre on sort Véronique
ça va bien et vous-même très bien et
donc depuis la semaine dernière il y a
un nouveau rendez-vous où nous proposez
sur les antennes de TV 70 sur l'antenne
de TV 78 les insolites de Véronique et
vous nous parlez des informations
insolites à ne pas louper dans le
département des Yvelines tant qu'à faire
à ne pas louper bien évidemment voilà
très rapidement ce soir
de moutons et de cité de l'histoire bon
on dit un peu plus tout à l'heure à
votre droite il y a Bernard Pinet
également bonsoir bonsoir alors comédien
vous avez une longue carrière derrière
vous puisque vous avez joué dans plus de
90 films homme de théâtre également avec
une trentaine de pièces à votre actif un
exemple parmi tant d'autres c'est le
dîner de cons forcément ça parle à tout
le monde de Francis Veber ou vous
incarniez Lucien cheval c'est bien ça et
vous venez nous parler d'une autre pièce
alors c'est apocalypse républicaine
c'est un seul en scène un 12 personnages
trois actes et donc de 2 et avec vous et
la lumière est signée à Elias attige la
musique Mozart c'est une comédie existe
en ciel qui est critique sur la société
le monde politique on va peut-être voir
d'ailleurs l'affiche
qui va nous être proposé dans un instant
on va peut-être pouvoir la voir on voit
d'ailleurs une Marianne qui a une petite
larme qui est cool symbole de la
République avant d'en parler Bernard
Pinault regarde tout de suite un extrait
qui a été tourné lors d'une l'une des
répétitions au théâtre de Bailly
regardez
Marcel Marcel ça suffit tranquille
tous les deux à la SPA Vous portez mon
nom toi tu es Marcel Maboul le frère de
Bibi Malou
et ici j'ai Jean Malo on est en
République et en République on est
gentil avec la diversité et puis le chat
est un chat pacifique qui respecte les
chiens ils mangent pas de souris et en
plus il est végétarien comme nous alors
s'il te plaît Marcel tu lui fous la paix
et tu fais le canard d'accord
alors on a entendu le nom de Jean Maboul
c'est un psy qui reçoit dans son cabinet
de Rennes-le-Château et il applique sa
méthode c'est la méthode Maboul c'est
quoi la méthode Maboul alors la méthode
Maboul parfaitement expliqué dans un
livre qui est un best-seller qui
s'appelle avec la méthode Maboul on perd
jamais la boule
vous l'avez écrit en quelques minutes ce
serait comment dire une erreur parce
qu'elle est très forte très puissante
elle transmute la matière humaine tout
ça est parfaitement expliqué dans dans
le spectacle
qui est une comédie en trois actes avec
les trois unités de temps de lieu
et d'histoire du théâtre classique
il y a cette consultation le chiffre
n'est pas innocent
Jean Maboul le père de Bibi Maboul et de
Marcel Maboul qui végétarien comme comme
ses enfants
reçoit lors de cette journée
un capitaine de gendarmerie
une infirmière un maire un professeur
d'histoire à Sciences Po une
péripatéticienne un député un
commissaire des professions qui peuvent
en dire long sur l'état de notre société
et que va-t-il découvrir faudra venir
voir la pièce mais que va-t-il découvrir
en quelques mots bah il va constater des
réalités qui qui font tristes
la pièce n'est contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser avec le titre apocalypse
républicaine on pourrait imaginer que
dans ce spectacle on va tirer à boulets
rouges sur les uns les unes les autres
donc c'est pas du tout le cas en
revanche sa prétention sa volonté son
but son objectif c'est d'être un
spectacle humaniste d'être un spectacle
qui met le dos ça fait triste qui
éclaire et qui est à réfléchir c'est
pour ça que jusqu'à présent c'est le cas
je souhaite qu'il y ait dans la mesure
des possibles un débat après la pièce
dans lequel ont été confrontés en tant
que public des personnes de droite de
gauche du centre d'ailleurs
et qui se sont retrouvés dans ce
spectacle dans le cadre du débat c'est à
réfléchir sur la société peut-être c'est
dérives aussi aujourd'hui c'est des
rives les
erreurs peut-être de de certaines
personnes il y a du stock des deux côtés
des mots ça claque on peut le dire oui
oui le journal et votre collègue il est
toute nouvelle Versailles il a
parfaitement écrit je le remercie
d'avoir porté attention à ce spectacle
l'idée dans le cas de ces échanges avec
ces patients il y a des hypothèses de
solution qui sont abordées il y a
personne dans baguette magique tout le
monde sait que c'est très dur d'avoir
une casquette politique quelle qu'elle
soit donc faut respecter leur souci
leurs conditions mais bon la politique
d'autruche est pas toujours obligatoire
le déni n'est pas une religion et il est
peut-être temps d'ouvrir les yeux dans
l'intérêt de la République et la
citoyenneté trois points de suspension
mais le tout aussi non sans humour parce
que c'est aussi un moyen important de
faire passer des messages on imagine
c'est l'objectif de d'être une petite
bougie dans dans des ténèbres qui se
sont répandus parmi nous de peut-être
suggérer des des mises des applications
des solutions sans prétention aucune
parce que les remèdes sont simples on
les connaît vous l'avez joué d'ailleurs
il me semble devant des députés des élus
République juste à côté de l'Assemblée
nationale chez Françoise qu'est-ce qu'il
pense de de cette pièce où vous êtes
aussi critique en ce moment de le monde
politique alors d'abord comment ça s'est
passé c'est dans le salon des premiers
ministres quand on joue au spectacle qui
s'appelle apocalypse républicaine c'est
assez coca c'est totalement inattendu
j'ai vu une lecture en Avignon dans le
quartier Louna cet été qui s'est bien
passé et là il y a une dame qui m'attend
qui me dit c'était bien bon discute et
elle prend mon téléphone et
en septembre fin septembre elle me dit
voilà est-ce que vous accepteriez de
lire votre pièce dans le salon des
premiers ministres
ma pomme là non non c'est très sérieux
alors le salon des premiers ministres un
salon qui existent dans un restaurant
très connu du monde politique qui
s'appelle chez Françoise qui en théorie
n'existe pas il est sous l'esplanade des
Invalides on est dans un parking et un
poste à l'entrée c'est un peu le
restaurant de James Bond à l'intérieur
c'est c'est très chouette c'est très bon
et effectivement midi et soir il y a il
y a des députés des sénateurs des hommes
politiques qui des fois se sont un peu
un peu secoués la veille et qui sont la
bise au restaurant ce qui est rassurant
pour les citoyens c'est un neuvième seul
en scène comme pétanque et sentiment
l'une de vos pièces qui a été un succès
avec plus de 300 représentations
pourquoi cette formule du seul en scène
comment dire après avoir joué un certain
nombre de spectacles après avoir fait le
dîner de consespérais après avoir joué
des déroule principaux au cinéma enfin
la télé oui ou sinon il y a très
longtemps j'espérais que ça allait
continuer gentiment non bon c'est des
mystères de d'un parcours je fais pas
une carrière vous avez parlé de carrière
mais je fais un parcours de c'est un
parcours de vie un parcours de
combattant du verbe
l'Apocalypse au commencement était le
Verbe le verbe ils m'ont pas entendu non
plus donc comme j'avais plein de choses
à dire pour ne plus m'entendre j'avais
dire que je n'étais pas bankable que je
n'étais pas people parce que je vis à la
campagne avec Marcel et bibli existent
c'est leur vrai nom avec mes chiens
etc bon je me suis dit c'est pas grave
faut connaissez la formule de Lao de
ceux qui a dit
on traduit dans le texte si tu trouves
que le monde va mal commence par te
changer toi-même voilà et je me suis
voilà et donc je me suis mis à écrire
mes spectacle c'est le neuvième ça se
passe plutôt bien je ne regrette rien ne
festivals d'Avignon de moins Molière et
des centaines de représentations donc
j'ai absolument pas le droit de me
plaindre merci à ceux qui m'ont pas fait
tourner au cinéma écrasé je peux faire
tout ça et du coup une dernière question
on vous l'avez dit une première lecture
au Festival d'Avignon depuis la pièce a
évolué maintenant l'objectif c'est quoi
c'est de la proposer et de faire une
tournée peut-être alors déjà au salon
des
des premiers ministres il y avait
Dominique tes yeux qui est la directrice
la patronne du quartier Louis en Avignon
qui est sur le plan culturel et quelque
chose d'important qui existe ou passe
beaucoup de d'excellents professionnels
qui a dit officiellement qu'elle me
programmer cet été donc ça c'est un
drapeau qui est planté au Festival
d'Avignon ça on en fera un de plus et
d'une de deux d'ici là il y a d'autres
lectures qui se sont mises en place je
continue sur le principe de lecture
pourquoi parce que notre métier n'a
jamais été facile personne ne peut
ignorer qu'en ce moment c'est encore un
peu plus sensible pour une suspension à
la ligne donc une lecture permet dans
des conditions très modestes de se
déplacer sans décor et de jouer dans un
théâtre comme je l'ai fait à Bali comme
je dois le faire dans d'autres de faire
des lectures dans des lieux petit comme
le salon des premiers ministres mais il
y aura une programmation dans un
contexte traditionnel à Paris soyez
patient je dirais votre site internet
qui s'affiche pour avoir toutes les
informations merci beaucoup mais vous
restez avec nous parce qu'on continue de
pas être petite réaction ce que je vous
voyais à casser ouais c'est pas une
période facile pour le pour le monde du
peuple le monde de culturel non non
c'est pas facile déjà il y a eu le covid
qui a fait beaucoup de dégâts maintenant
avec toutes les augmentations qui se
font un peu partout c'est compliqué la
guerre de l'Ukraine qui n'arrange pas
les choses oui c'est compliqué pour le
pour le spectacle et le théâtre comme
moyen de dénonciation c'est un excellent
vecteur
vous me prenez au dépourvil
on va dire et je prendrai pas je rends
la parole et le monde du théâtre après
une bombe à retardement qui sont les
factures d'électricité et le théâtre qui
ferme parce que les factures sont
devenus colossales j'espère que nos amis
politiques ont en ont ils peuvent plus
suivre j'ai des jours
c'est vrai que c'est très intéressant ce
que ce que vous dites c'est vrai
ouais je suis diabétrage
diamétralement différent de ma mère
de se lancer et on va parler
un peu plus XXL avec un peu plus de
comédiens
mais on parle justement de de cette
pièce que vous êtes en train de créer un
premier temps une une première mondiale
pour packsart production donc je le
disais tout à l'heure Hardel ou la
marguerite une pièce de Jean anouil donc
qui est mise en scène par vous
Christophe Jacquet donc pacsart
production a lancé une levée de fonds
pour réaliser dans les meilleures
conditions ce projet juste sur Hardel ou
la marguerite c'est une pièce qui a été
créée en 1948 je disais par Jean Reno
qui se veut imaginaire et aussi qui met
en avant la fantaisie des personnages on
y parle d'amour dans cette pièce si on
peut la marguerite vous les feuillez
vous les feuillez il a Marguerite je
t'aime un peu beaucoup passionnément
donc oui bien sûr et on retrouve tous
les thèmes chers amis le paradis perdu
de l'enfance la condition sociale
tous ces thèmes sont abordés de cette
pièce là qui a cette chance d'être peu
connue bon moi c'est un auteur qui me
fascine toujours quand tu es forcément
l'écriture moderne d'Antigone
Hardel le la marguerite
sur Antigone c'est
plus parce que ça fait plus partie de
notre langage et donc quand on voit une
pièce avec des mots compliqués c'est
difficile à suivre une pièce alors que
cette pièce là Marguerite c'est léger
c'est simple à comprendre il y a pas
besoin de chercher en fait et sur la
mise en scène 10 comédien un décor avec
très sport des costumes de la musique
comment vous avez pensé justement cette
mise en scène un travail d'un an il me
semble oui travaille dans
la première chose que je tiens à dire
puisque déjà nous remercions parce que
nous avons le soutien quand même de la
fille de Jean anouil donc de Colombes à
nouilles le
premier axe de travail était de la lire
la lire c'est vrai que bon
et toi un inconditionnel danoï donc
c'est difficile peut-être aussi de
chercher celle-ci avait quelque chose de
Picot comme comme le dit comme le dit
Mathilde et après c'était aussi de
savoir de se dire qu'est-ce que je vais
en faire et je suis quelqu'un qui suit
très respectueux d'un auteur d'une œuvre
donc j'ai très peu touché au texte de
trois coupures chose un peu redondantes
voilà et
je suis quelqu'un qui attache une
importance extrême à l'esthétisme donc
pour construire gérer ma
mise enceinte j'avais besoin de partir
de l'esthétique c'est vrai que à nous il
y a quand même des idées il y a ces
grandiose puisque c'est un escalier qui
fait le tour de la Seine avec une
galerie c'est impossible n'est-ce pas
Mathilde merci non mais c'est pas c'est
pas possible les tout et c'était de se
poser la question qu'est-ce comment je
vais recréer un peu et je suis reparti
une notion de base de tout théâtre du
texte des indications et par le qui a un
ensemble de portes et je me suis dit
tiens là ça devient comment ça devenir
intéressant mais j'ai essayé de réécrire
la mise en scène en fonction justement
de la scène est un mur de mort de presse
porte semi circulaire toutes ces portes
peuvent s'ouvrir ou pas donc à des
moments donnés on est proche du
boulevard ou les portes claques ou à des
moments donnés quand il y a justement ce
procès un peu d'ardèle savoir ce qu'on
va ce qu'on va faire cette pauvre
arnelle tout devient fermé et clos donc
ça c'était vraiment ma première idée et
après je sais pour avoir lu que même
beaucoup de choses autour de gens à
nouer il aime bien ce côté
191913 donc c'était aussi pour moi
important de la remettre un peu dans ce
contexte 1910 1913 fin de avant la début
de la Première Guerre mondiale
Edgar tout en ayant quelques anacronisme
alors concrètement où est-ce qu'on en
est aujourd'hui ce que l'ambition c'est
de la jouer en France à l'étranger aussi
en France et alors on va d'abord
commencer par par la France et ensuite à
l'étranger ensuite Belgique et plus loin
si dans les pays francophones en fait
donc des dates sont déjà prévues
sont pas encore totalement prévu
puisqu'il est prévu de faire notre
premier représentation en octobre de
cette année
après faut chercher pour l'étranger en
fait et c'est un petit peu plus long et
je le disais vous avez lancé levée de
fonds
spectacle il est pas question d'en faire
un petit spectacle avec des petits
moyens les costumes seront plus ou moins
d'époque comme l'a dit Christophe parce
qu'il y a eu aussi une partie où il y a
des départs sur scène qui vont être un
peu plus modernes et donc et le décor va
être aussi assez faramineux pas aussi
grandiose que Jean anouil il avait fait
à l'époque mais important pour qu'il
soit suffisamment
qu'on se souvienne en fait de la pièce
voilà et comme on a l'intention d'en
faire un grand spectacle et ben ça ça
coûte donc automatiquement c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin d'un on a fait une levée
de fonds parce que le spectacle au
niveau du budget est important on
retrouve toutes les informations
d'ailleurs sur le site de paxa
production pour trouver assez facilement
le lien sur donc cette pièce cette
création Hardel ou la marguerite de gens
à nous qui sera donc proposé par vous
votre
production et donc vous Christophe
Jacquier à la mise en scène vous avez
fait votre choix pour calibre
républicaine moi je prends tout vous
prenez tout direct
avec vous comme chèque mardi Véronique
je me tourne vers vous on va présenter
les informations insolites du
département des Yvelines on va commencer
d'ailleurs tout de suite par une
initiative de la mairie de
Triel-sur-Seine qui propose aux femmes
des stages de self-défense exactement
alors j'ai trouvé cette information
passionnante dans Le Parisien et donc à
Triel-sur-Seine il n'y a pas plus de
violence skyr c'est juste pareil sauf
que un des élus un élu de la
municipalité et l'élu à la sécurité et
professeur d'art martials martiaux
martial bref et il a eu lui-même cette
idée donc de proposer aux femmes deux
heures de cours par mois le dimanche
matin gratuit on peut y aller à partir
de 15 ans et on vous explique certaines
clés pour savoir se défendre en cas de
l'agression alors tous ces
renseignements c'est David désiré le
chef de service de la police municipale
qui me les a gentiment donné alors déjà
on apprend en quelques mots si possible
évitez l'agression il y a des choses à
déjà être attentif ne pas avoir un
casque sur les oreilles être un peu
ouvert à son environnement ne pas être
les yeux rivés sur le smartphone ou même
changer de chemin pas prendre toujours
le même chemin ne pas hésiter à fuir
quand on sent quelque chose on bref si
malheureusement on en arrive à
l'agression comment rester debout
essayer d'apaiser la situation bon
facile à dire dialoguer si possible ou
si ça me fait un peu rire c'est pas
drôle mais si vous arrivez par bonheur à
faire tomber l'agresseur n'attendez pas
qu'il se relève ça va pas trop mal non
on s'en va
toutes les intentions il y a une
inscription qui est obligatoire qui
s'affiche en va continuer avec un livre
ou un projet de livre écrit en hommage à
André Moret alors André Moret les gens
ne savent pas forcément qui c'est ce fut
un maître berger qui a exercé son métier
à la bergerie de Rambouillet en 1935
entre 1935 et 1970 et qui incarne à la
fois tradition côté innovateur de ce
lieu formidable qui est à la ber
Nationale de Rambouillet complètement
alors c'est Patrice Angot qui est un
homme passionné par l'agriculture le
monde rural l'agriculture propre saine
respectueuse qui a d'ailleurs créé un
musée agricole à l'intérieur de la
bergerie de Rambouillet et qui a eu
l'idée d'écrire ce livre en hommage à
André Moret qui est un maître berger
alors moi comme d'hab j'ai 1929 1970 peu
importe il a eu un troupeau de 650 tête
alors le matin il se fait 24 heures il
allait s'occuper des bêtes et après il
enseignait l'art d'être maître berger et
ce n'est pas rien voilà c'est un livre
donc qui est bourré d'anecdotes
Patrice Angot l'a fait avec l'aide de
Philippe Moret le fils d'André Le Maître
berger on y apprend plein de choses il y
a des archives incroyables inédites des
photos
de Gaulle est venu le voir André Moret
plein de réparti lui a dit je préfère
garder mon troupeau que le vôtre la
femme de René Coty aller chercher ses
fromages enfin il y a tout un tas de
d'anecdotes passionnantes il était très
fort en généalogie pour les mérinos
voilà il faisait attention à la
consanguinité et alors le mérino c'est
la meilleure laine qui existe ça je ne
vous apprends rien quand il fait chaud
vous avez un peu frais et quand il fait
froid vous avez chaud on ne le quitte
pas sur mérinos voilà en
souscriptions qui sont affichés si on
veut aider la parution de ce livre on
termine avec un verset de coeur hauteur
d'ailleurs du Dictionnaire amoureux de
Versailles c'est Franck Ferrand qui
prend la tête de la cité de l'histoire
c'est quoi cette cité de l'histoire
alors là c'était de l'histoire elle est
à la défense elle vient de d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui c'est un projet qui existe
depuis 18 mois qui a été conçu en un an
avec 400 intervenants et certains ont
travaillé jour et nuit et Franck Ferrand
notre ami historien sur les ondes de
Radio Classique à la télévision on est
le directeur voilà et le
le but de cette énorme lieu c'est de
vous permettre de vous immerger alors
c'est la grande mode en ce moment
l'immersion parle que de ça et là
vraiment immersion totale dans la
réalité virtuelle voilà 12 siècles
d'histoire vous avez avoir des pièces
avec des comédiens vous allez plonger
dans des époques particulières vous
allez avoir tout un une scénographie
autour de Victor Hugo vous allez pouvoir
visiter Notre-Dame comme si vous y étiez
de plusieurs points de vue
enfin bref c'est c'est il y aura des
conférences qui vont changer
régulièrement il y a une librairie un
restaurant face à un endroit où on peut
aller plusieurs fois il y a une frise
chronologique géante avec des bornes
interactives on pourra appuyer sur les
dates qui vous intéressent plus ou moins
enfin un truc de dingue très futuriste
très futuriste et en même temps parlant
de d'époque très très ancienne voilà ce
futur grâce à la technologie on revient
on revient dans le dans le passé voilà
j'en tousse
dans tous ces merci c'est ainsi
qu'on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour d'autres idées insolites d'autres
informations insolites un petit tour de
table et ce que la cuisine italienne
c'est une cuisine qui vous plaît
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque Véronique
ouais ça m'évoque le soleil la
générosité la convivialité Rome Venise
être tout à l'état il y a
la Méditerranée les spaghettis les
pizzas dont je suis un gros consommateur
moi aussi
les Italiens qui ont des natures
joyeuses festives plein d'énergie est-ce
que ça vous plaît aussi de l'autre côté
de la table
des grands amateurs
l'Italie c'est les tomates c'est la base
de tout dans la cuisine italienne et oui
et donc chaque mardi c'est aussi un
rendez-vous à un côté des insolites de
Véronique désormais on propose aussi à
noter les spectateurs l'astuce du chef
autrement dit comment briller en cuisine
grâce à nos chefs du territoire et en
cette Journée mondiale et de la cuisine
italienne Ludivine canard et Patrick
Jacques de dixmus sont allés à la
rencontre d'un chef pizzaïolo à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il nous livre ses
secrets pour bien réaliser sa pâte à
pizza chez soi regarder
[Musique]
la recette de ma pâte c'est 10 litres
d'eau 20 kg de farine 400 g de sel 40 g
de levure après on le fait faire un tour
seulement un tour
[Musique]
oui il ne faut pas toucher les bords le
bord c'est la pizza avec le bord il ne
faut pas le toucher le bas il faut
laisser un peu bomber au milieu comme ça
ne vient pas très fin au milieu
[Musique]
la plus importante c'est tomate alors
quand on dit
qu'on fait la pizza la pizza on le fait
pas avec la mozza on le fait avec le
fleur de lait c'est ça le fil de base de
la pizza sont presque tous de qualité
[Musique]
beaucoup ils m'ont demandé pourquoi chez
nous elle ne sort pas comme chez vous
ces questions de température et question
de four professionnel elle doit être et
pour cuire les ingrédients
[Musique]
sinon tu ne peux pas le faire à la
maison à la maison elle sort comme un
disque
[Musique]
pourquoi les gens aiment la pizza parce
qu'elle est plus rapide plus rapide de
ça coûte moins cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà bon appétit toi c'est l'heure
bientôt de passer à table avant de vous
laisser un dernier coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
une journée très fraîche en prévision ce
mardi dans les Yvelines des éclaircies
le matin mais surtout des températures
négatives dans la partie est issue du
département à moins un degré à
Versailles Rambouillet 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan dans
l'après-midi ça remonte légèrement pas
de pluie au moins côté température il
fera 5 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 4 degrés
à Versailles ou dans les Rambouillet ce
mercredi 18 janvier c'est la saint
Prisca voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8
merci de votre fidélité Merci à VOUS
autour de la table d'avoir été avec moi
au cours de cette heure d'émission et
demain pour un nouveau 7 8 une nouvelle
édition vous retrouverez Mathilde Franco
à la présentation belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]